every 28 hours in this country a black
person is murdered by security officers
police officers or vigilantes there are
more people in prisons and jails today
than there were enslaved in this country
yeah everybody's seen the hash tag at
this point they've seen the slogans in
the protests what is black lives matter
and how did it come about black lives
matter is a project that's designed to
celebrate the humanity the brilliance
and resilience of black people in a
world that devalues black life and we
use black lives matter as a place where
folks can come together online and
offline to collaborate to strategize to
build power together we've seen the hash
tag take off but we've also seen spins
on that hash tag like all lives matter
what do you think about that well I
think that it points towards a utopian
reality that we don't live in right now
so when you look at what's going on in
the streets right now and the protests
that have been basically non-stop for a
couple months do you think that this is
the birth of a new national movement and
if so what is the movement young people
have decided that enough is enough and
that it's no longer time for slow
incremental change or for compromise and
that what we need right now are radical
shifts in our social system in our
economic system and in our criminal
system and we need folks who have been
in the movement for a long time to
really be supporting their capacity to
win do you think that al Sharpton should
actually step aside not be in front of
the camera and maybe put forward a
younger face it's a different moment
today and so the needs are different the
conditions are different and so it's
really important that leaders and elders
in particular are listening to what's
changed and listening to what's needed
from those who are directly and mostly
impacted can you name some of the
younger people who are just as involved
that we might not know about folks like
the black youth project folks like
millennial activists United in Ferguson
and Tribe X in Ferguson and st. Louis
hands up United in Ferguson the dream
defenders dignity and power now in Los
Angeles so there's obviously so much
momentum right now
for the movement and the news cycle is
very much tuned in to what's going on
but where does it go from here making
sure that we are really moving towards
pushing for our demands to be adopted in
at the federal level at the state level
and at the municipal level that there is
adequate and consistent data that is
collected across the country about
police killings and officer-involved
shootings right now police departments
individually can decide what they track
and what they don't how they report and
how they don't so we need a consistent
standard for that another demand that
young people are moving in this moment
is that there be accountability measures
attached to that data and so if a police
department shows a pattern of
discriminatory policing that they
wouldn't be receiving federal funding in
other words our tax dollars to promote
and continue racism there's been tons of
peaceful protests all over there's also
been some incidents of vandalism and
things getting a little more violent
what tactics do you advocate and where
do you draw the line we advocate those
types of tactics that really shake up
the comfort level what do you say to
people who critics what do you say to
critics who say you know smashing
property windows and in storefronts and
some looting is actually
counterproductive to the movement my
response to that would be do we have the
same level of outrage when a window gets
broken as we do when a young black
person is killed in our communities and
if we don't there's a real disparity
there and we need to figure out what
that is
once we did you know it was beautiful